Joining the session, can you guys all hear me?
If you cannot hear me, you can use the the
headsets which we have on the back.
I'm Vivek Chauhan.
I'll be presenting this session with my friend and colleague
Jed.
We also have a special guest Nico from Harvey.
He'll be joining the call.
Today we're going to talk about how you can save
a ton of money and build application specific production graze
inference optimized AI using open source models there are using
fireworks and then how you can serve those models for
inference on foundry.
Cool.
OK, let's get started.
There are three fundamental truths we believe in the AI's
landscape right now.
Number one, for all practical purposes for most enterprise use
cases, the gap between open weight models and frontier closed
models has collapsed.
What it means is that a lot of the companies
can switch to an open weight model if they want
to while keeping the same quality bar and save a
ton of money as compared to pointing let's say clawed
Opus 4.7 for an e-mail summarization task.
You can use a smaller model and open weight model
and get to the same quality and save money.
The second thing, the true differentiation only comes from actually
embedding your own data mode into the AI.
If you are using the same close weight model which
everyone of your competitor is using, there is no differentiation.
If you wanted to redifferentiate your own AI stack, leveraging
fine tuning is actually very key.
And 3rd and the most important thing, the most leading
companies in this space which we see on our platform
are actually going beyond just inference or inference optimization or
fine tuning.
They are continuously improving their AI stack and they are,
they have found a flywheel on our platform through which
they can actually have a very differentiated mode.
And we'll talk about how leveraging fireworks, you can get
the same mode on your platform.
And we have the platform on fireworks AI side where
we provide world class inference and training.
So we'll cover that also.
OK, a little bit about Fireworks AI, We process more
than 30 trillion tokens per day.
It's actually right behind Frontier close weight labs like cloud
and and Tropic and open AI.
We saw more than 10,000 enterprise customers globally who leverage
our platform to build production blade applications using open weight
models.
You have some names on the screen cursor actually leverage
our RL rollout capabilities to build Composer 2, Composer 2.5
models.
We have customers like Versal, Genspark, Uber, Do Dash, a
long list of customers who lean on us for better
quality through fine tuning and training, better performance.
It could be speed, it could be throughput, time to
first look on whatever is your application specific need.
We're able to take care of that using a platform.
How do we do that?
We have our own inference engine, our own inference stack.
If you think about it, LLM inference actually is a
very, very difficult and very brutal combinatorial problem.
Across optimizations on speculative decoding or quantization modes, various different
queues you have access to, different parallelization strategies.
There's more than 85,000 permutations, 84,000 permutations for one model
which you want to serve.
For most companies, it does not make sense to actually
deal with this complexity in house.
They would rather focus on their users, their application and
leaner platform.
Because we keep up with this space.
This space is moving too fast.
We deal with everything in terms of the Kuda kernels,
in terms of quantization, spell decoding, adaptive caching.
Every new fancy AI optimization trick which comes out, we
embed that in our stack.
You don't have to worry about it.
You can focus on your application and we can take
care of your specific needs.
I want my time to 1st token to be less
than 500 millisecond.
I want my N 20 density to be less than
two seconds.
I want my throughput to be such.
We can take care of that using our inference engine.
And all of these inference engine capabilities are now available
on Foundry, and we'll talk about that.
We'll do a live demo of that.
This slide actually is my favorite slide.
We want all companies to actually own their AI stack.
Its paramount that companies do that and we want to
meet customers where they are in their journey.
Different companies are actually in different stages of their AI
journey.
In fact within a company also different teams are in
different stage of their AI journey.
We want to find a way to meet them where
they are.
We have a training agent which is more targeted towards
product managers and app builders.
The training agent basically can take your data and your
business use case and it can give you a fine-tuned
model, will give you a live demo, will give you
a demo of the of the agent.
Right now we have a managed training platform which is
more targeted towards ML engineers.
If you already know what training method you want to
use, you already have a data set which you have
want to use.
You can literally just port the data set and kick
off a training job on the platform.
You do not have to worry about any of the
back end infrastructure orchestration.
We take care of that.
If you are an advanced ML team, if you are
researchers, you actually would love our training API product.
With the training API product, we expose the raw primitives
of the platform, custom loss functions, reward functions, advanced algo
suite.
If you want access to highest context window, full parameter
fine tuning, we provide that in our training API and
we'll talk about that.
Basically, we have a, we have a surface from high
to very low controls depending on what you want.
And you can actually meet your key needs in one
platform.
And no matter what surface you use, you can one
click deploy in the platform, which is very, very important
for speed of iteration as coming to training somewhere and
doing inference somewhere else, downloading, reformatting.
You don't have to deal with any of that.
One click deploy, run your evals, cheaper to production.
And this is the flywheel I was talking about.
We have seen, we are already seeing leading companies in
the space find this flywheel on our platform and they're
actually spinning faster and faster.
They are training models on the platform, they're deploying it
on the platform, they're monitoring it, They're getting the traces
out of it, they're retraining it.
And they're able to do that on our platform because
we take care of the complex part.
We take care of the GPU orchestrations.
You don't need to scavenge for GPUs.
You don't need to worry about elasticity.
You don't need to worry about bad notes or CSP
issues.
That's our headache.
We take care of just the core part of the
the family itself in terms of like putting the weights
over hot loading, checkpointing.
That's not your pain point as compared to doing this
DIY in house, which might take you many, many weeks.
You can probably get 10 iterations done in fireworks.
The third thing is we guarantee numerical fidelity for you.
It's actually a very big thing when you're training a
large model, when you're training an NMOE model which is
using floating point precision, the numerics can drift a lot.
What you train on might not be what you serve
on.
And we guarantee numerics where you don't have to worry
about that.
You can be assured that what I trained, the results
I got is matching the production platform performance for my
end users.
And again, no vendors for all.
Everything is in one platform, training and inference, one click
deploy and you know you can focus on an application
and leave the infrastructure to us.
OK, enough with the slides.
Let's do some live demo, actually recorded demo.
So I'm going to start with a demo of the
training agent.
The idea is very simple actually.
Let me ask a question first.
How many of you love writing evals and reformatting data?
No one.
OK, so the agent is for you.
The idea behind the agent is very simple.
You speak in plain English.
This is my data set, this is my business goal,
and you help me fine tune a model.
The agent can reformat the data.
The agent can write evals for you.
The agent can help you find a model which might
be good for your use case.
The agent can do hyperparameter search for you.
So usually when you are doing a fine tuning of
the model, there are so many knobs you can tweak
to get to the output you're looking for.
And its extremely actually very painful to go through all
the permutations manually, 1 by 1.
You don't have to do that.
We have an agent which can take your business use
case, deal with model selection, evaluating data formatting, and it
can give you a plan and the plan will outline
what the agent is proposing.
It can also tell you upfront what it will cost
you to do this training iteration.
Once you're happy with the plan at a high level,
you can just say, OK, you know what, approve, go
ahead.
Then the agent will take your data set, make a
small cut of the data set, and do the hyperparameter
grid search on that data set to narrow down the
sample space.
And once it has narrowed down the sample space, it
will ask you again.
OK, you know what?
I tried like these ten different iterations.
These are the 2 which are the most promising.
This is the reason why it's more promising along with
the eval results.
Do you want me to do a full run?
The full data set run on the platform?
Once you say yes, the agent will take your full
data set and it will actually do the whole training
run on your full data set.
It will give you a very comprehensive, like step by
step view of what's happening under the hood and it
will give you a final report.
In the end, Everything which I'm showing here on the
screen is actually available in headless fashion.
So we have a skill file.
If you want to train a modeler directly from your
own coding agent, from your own harness, Kittup, Copilot, clod,
cursor, you name it, you can just drop the skill
file, add your API keys and you're good to go.
It also gives you suggestions what else you could do
if you want to do more iterations on top of
it.
The agent can take care of your supervised fine tuning
needs.
It can take care of preference optimization needs.
It can help you make a model for classification tasks.
All of that is packaged already.
OK, so agent is for people who do not want
to like deal with the ML part of it.
We also have a very simple clickable workflow.
If you want to just train a model and you
have a data set already, and if you know which
method you want to use, what hyperparams you want to
use, what I'm showing on the screen is our managed
training product.
You can come into the platform and you can choose
supervised fine tuning, reinforcement, fine tuning, preference optimization, and just
just select the workflow you want to go with.
You can choose the model.
We are usually day zero provider for open weight models
for inference.
That also means we are the fastest providers for supporting
fine tuning on open weight models.
You can come in here, select the model you want.
Once you have selected the model, you can upload the
data set directly.
We also provide secure training, so you can actually stream
data BYOB directly from your own cloud.
And we expose raw parameters where you can choose the
epochs, the learning rate, the batch size.
A lot of like smart defaults are available out-of-the-box to
you and you can basically kick off a training job.
If you want to do reinforcement fine tuning, there is
one additional step.
Basically you have to upload your grader or connect your
grader using your GitHub repo so that they reinforcement tuning
job can use a grader to actually give rewards to
the agent, to the model.
And again, we expose features where you can change your
different knobs, top K, top P, etc.
Along with that size learning rate, we also support weights
and biases.
So if you want more detailed telemetry, you can just
plug in your API key and get weights and biases
so you can actually monitor what's happening under the hood.
If you want to do preference optimization that's also supported
similar setup.
Upload the data, choose the configs you want to run,
run as many times as you want to run.
All your trained models show up on the platform and
while the training job is going on, you can actually
monitor the results live on the platform.
It will show you the loss function or the reward
function in real time.
So you can see if it's behaving it's supposed to
behave or not.
You can pause something if it's not behaving, redo the
the reward functions or whatever eval you have picked up
for the for the job.
The best part of this this whole thing is that
you can one click deploy.
You do not have to worry about downloading the way
it's reformatting it, uploading it somewhere, worry about numerics and
just waste time on it.
Just one click deploy on the platform.
And also we provide compound training.
So you can take a supervised fine-tuned model and then
do DPO on top of it.
Then take a DPO model, do reinforcement learning on top
of it and you can do as many iterations or
passes as you want.
That is the flywheel I was talking about of continuous
iteration and continuous training.
What happens once you train the model?
This is the part where we talk about inference and
doing dedicated deployment.
So we support on demand deployment of these fine-tuned models.
Again, we support the largest array of open weight models
you can do inference on just like base model on
the platform if you want to.
We also support inference on the fine-tuned model which I
was talking about.
So basically just come and select the model.
One thing which is interesting here, remember I was talking
about how using our fire optimizer capabilities were able to
give you custom shapes of the model specific to your
own traffic.
You are seeing an example here.
The same model on the same number of GPUs can
give you very different performance depending on how you have
orchestrated and packaged the whole GPU stack from CUDA kernels
to spec decoding to everything around it.
We are seeing an example here.
The same model can be served in a minimal shape
way or a full precision shape way can be served
for optimized for speed, optimized for throughput.
So the screen is showing you selecting a custom tuned
model and you can choose the shape you want depending
on your applications need and basically one click deploy that
shape on the model.
We also support auto scaling, so you don't have to
worry about peaks and troughs of your traffic that we
already scale up and scale down as your traffic shifts.
And yeah, that's how the deployment works.
I also talked about the training API a couple of
slides before.
What is the training API?
If you want raw power of the platform exposed to
you because you're an advanced ML user, this is what
you need.
We take care of everything behind the scene in terms
of infra, but still give you all the Norse exposed
to you.
You can write your own custom loss functions.
You can, you know, go with the latest and greatest
algorithms out there.
Everybody is talking about on policy registration right now, Cisco.
All these things are available and then you have full
parameter fine tuning.
We have a cookbook which has a bunch of recipes
in a GitHub repo which is publicly available.
You don't have to write something from scratch if you
don't want to just pick a recipe chain the knobs.
The beauty about this particular product is that you can
train the model from within your harness, and that's actually
very important.
AI needs to learn how to do the job better,
but it needs to learn how to do the job
better from within your environment, from within your harness, knowing
which tools it has access to and how to orchestrate
these tools.
With the training API, we are giving those capabilities to
you Well.
Also talk a little bit about harness and AI model
coming together for fine tuning as we go to the
later half of the session.
And there's a bunch of examples which you can use
to, to get started.
You don't have to worry about like writing something from
scratch.
You can train A1 trillion parameter model from your laptop
and we take care of all the infra.
Cool.
OK.
So we also want to talk about an exciting announcement
we had yesterday on Satya's keynote about fireworks being available
on Foundry.
Everything which I showed you in terms of inference deployment
is available on Foundry.
The training side is not.
You can train a model on Fireworks and you can
download it and move it to a custom model deployment
on Foundry.
So you're not, you don't have to worry about that.
And we have an announcement video.
And now, which is the exciting thing that we're here
together to announce is the general availability of Fireworks in
Microsoft Foundry and how customers can not only take all
of the greatness that Fireworks has to offer, but also
all of the greatness that Foundry has to offer in
a simplified way, 1 endpoint, one contract and one journey,
one platform.
So I'm super excited.
Thank you, Lean.
It's been an amazing partnership with your team.
Thank you, Vivek, for introducing Fireworks.
Now what you're all here for today in terms of
how Fireworks actually fits on Foundry and how to go
from that model catalog on Azure Foundry all the way
into production, it's actually quite straightforward.
And before we even get into that in a demo,
let's talk about why customers choose Fireworks on Foundry specifically
for mainly 4 key reasons.
One, because of performance.
So my colleague Vivek actually introduced our inference engine that
helps you do optimization from a CUDA kernel level up.
And so when customers come to us, we can actually
optimize for their specific use case and give the most
out of the GPU when the model sits on top
of the GPU for their inferencing needs and use case.
The second reason being the model advantage.
Most of the models that are released on fireworks, we
release it on day zero.
So when Deep V4 came out or the Kimi 2.6
came out, we tried our best to release all these
state-of-the-art open source models on day zero.
So you can plug it into your agents as soon
as they come out.
The third reason being more of control and extensibility itself.
So a lot of the custom models can now be
deployed on Foundry through the integration of Fireworks and Azure
Foundry Catalog itself.
The last being economics.
This is what most customers really, really care about.
When you start scaling these closed source models specifically in
your applications, they get really expensive really quickly.
So what customers are looking for is a cheaper alternative
at the same time meeting the quality that these close
source models give.
And that's what the models on Fireworks actually provide.
And integrated with Azure Foundry, it's even more easier for
you to use up these Azure credits that you have
on Foundry itself.
So that there are three main integration modes that customers
use when integrating fireworks with Foundry.
The first being serverless.
These are models that are deployed on Foundry and you
don't really have to create a deployment per SE.
It's already created.
It's a shared deployment among multiple users.
It is per token basis.
You'll be charged per token when you use this particular
model on Foundry.
So we have a lot state-of-the-art OSS models available today
through Foundry.
In this particular mode that is the serverless or pay
as you go mode.
We have GLM 5.1, Kimi 2.6, GPT 120B and we
are releasing models as they come as well.
The second mode being mode, the PTU or provisional throughput
mode.
This is when you already have a production workload in
mind and you want to reserve some GPUs and deploy
a model for your specific use case.
This is PTU gated and it works really, really well
for production workload specifically.
And then the last one being bring your own weights.
A lot of the customers, when they come to us
and when they're especially competing with closed source models, they
have trained open source models to compete with them in
terms of quality.
And when they have their own models that they have
trained and the custom weights, they want to deploy it
on Foundry.
So like Vivek mentioned, you can chain these models on
Fireworks and then download the model weights, upload it to
Azure and deploy it on Azure and use your Azure
credits for that particular deployment itself.
This particular integration architecture deployment work, deployment mode works very
well when you have trained proprietary models and you wanna
use that in your application.
Now that we know a little bit about what the
Azure and Fireworks integration is about, let's talk a little
bit about what customers are saying about this integration itself.
One, our friends at UI Path actually wanted a faster
and more cost effective model.
Not only that, they actually wanted a model, an open
source model to beat the quality of a closed source
Sonnet 4.6 model.
And this was achievable by using models on Fireworks and
Azure Foundry.
And then there there are stakeholders from Bolt knew what
they were looking for, for their application was something that
can scale well in terms of throughput and latency for
their production use case.
And this was definitely possible.
And their particular, we found a solution for their particular
problem using the Azure ecosystem and the fireworks model.
Lastly, some of the key decision makers at Motif were
actually trying to have models run a repeatable task and
also at a high volume workload.
And to support that specific workload, they deployed models on
Azure Foundry that was also optimized using the using the
engine that Fireworks has and we were able to serve
that particular repeatable high volume workload itself.
Now that we know a bit about what customers are
telling us and what that integration is about, let's look
at quick demos on this particular section itself.
So when customers actually come to the Azure Foundry platform,
they can go to the Discover page as pointed to
in this particular video.
And then in the catalog itself, go to the models
page and look at the model catalogs.
And within these model catalogs, if you want to find
all the Fireworks models and that are optimized on Fireworks,
most of them have the prefix called FW.
For using the serverless pay as you go method.
You can just click on this particular model and then
click on deploy.
Once customer click on deploy, it asks you whether you
want to set some custom settings.
These custom settings actually are settings that you can configure
based on the PTU or the rate limits that you
are interested.
All serverless models that are deployed through Azure and Fireworks
actually have some kind of rate limit because it's shared
infrastructure.
So you can talk this particular switch to figure out
what kind of rate limits you want to set.
And once you do and you click deploy, you will
actually see a screen as shown above and you can
chat with the model.
In fact, you can even use the API itself to
plug into your agents or applications that you do have.
You might be wondering, OK, great, I can use a
model that already exists in the catalog, but what do
I do if I care about my custom models itself?
In this case, you can even upload your custom models.
So you might have to train these models on fireworks
and download these models.
But once you do, actually uploading it and deploying it
is quite straightforward and it's just a bunch of clicks.
In this particular video, it actually shows you how to
deploy these custom models.
You go to the build section of Azure itself and
once you do and go to the model pages, instead
of going to the deployments, you go to the custom
model section.
Over here you have a button that says Add.
This lets you add your own custom models.
You can name it whatever you want and choose the
base architecture.
If the base architecture is not by default supported, then
you can contact Azure and Fireworks and we will help
you enable it on Azure itself.
And once you do have it, you've got to use
this command line, command line prompt that it actually gave
you to upload your custom model to Azure.
And once it's uploaded, it's very easy to deploy.
You just click on the custom model that you have
on the platform and you click deploy.
It's as simple as that.
And because this is your particular deployment, you don't really
have any rate limits and you can decide how many
Ptus or provision throughput you want to provision for this
particular deployment itself.
And very similar to what we saw before, once this
model is ready, you can go to the UI and
chat with the model or use the API itself to
integrate with your applications or agents.
Say you have your models, either custom or existing based
models on Azure ready and you want to actually deploy
these models through the Azure agents itself.
How do you do that?
That's a question that a lot of customers ask us.
And I'll quickly show you a demo on how to
plug in the fireworks models on Foundry into the agents
that you found on in the Azure catalog itself.
So when you go to the build page, you will
see even a step to look at the agents that
are existing on your Azure account.
And you can name your agent whatever you want and
click on deploy.
Once you deploy, you can change the models that works
behind this particular agent itself.
It'll just take a couple of minutes to deploy.
And as you can see, it lists a bunch of
models that the agent can use.
You can choose a fireworks model that already exists on
Foundry or you can even choose a custom model.
You can even integrate these agent with different tools.
It can be web search tools, it can be tools
that you define or functions that you define as well.
And the agent will work really well with the tools
along with the fireworks model that you have integrated the
agent with.
So this is all well and good.
And you might be wondering, OK, let's hear actual customer
talk about deploying their their application and agents using this
fireworks and Azure Foundry itself.
And for that today here we have Nico.
A quick round of applause for Nico.
He'll be talking about Harvey and how they used Azure
and Fireworks itself.
Awesome thank you so much Nico for for joining.
Nico leads the applied research team at Harvey AI.
Harvey AI is a can you guys not hear us
is the mic for kick OK better now OK awesome
yeah.
Nico leads the applied research team at Harvey AI.
Harvey is the leading native AI startup and and it
is used by hundreds of leading legal firms around the
globe.
And two weeks ago, 3 weeks ago, they launched the
new benchmark for legal lab legal agent benchmark.
So we're excited to talk about the benchmark.
We're excited to talk about how we're using, working together,
open weight models, closes models and orchestrating and getting to
a really good price performance for applications.
OK, awesome.
You're going to talk a little bit about Harvey and
the benchmark itself.
Sure, happy to and thanks for having me incredible event.
So my name is Nico Grupin, I'm the head of
applied research at Harvey.
Harvey is of course the generative AI platform for legal
and professional services.
We serve actually thousands of, of law firms across the
world and our mission is to make the work that
lawyers do more efficient, higher quality and reduce the busy
work within legal.
So as, as was kind of alluded to three weeks
ago, we'd launched legal agent benchmark.
As agents sort of proliferate in the application layer, one
of the biggest questions on the top of all of
our minds are what does it mean in terms of
quality?
How do I think about quality in my respective vertical
or domain?
That's what lab for short is intended to, to to
address.
So it's a benchmark to measure the performance of long
horizon agents on legal tasks.
So what does that mean?
There's really 4 components here.
The first is the agent's environment.
So the agent's environment is effectively a client matter.
A client matter is the term that we use to
describe the universe of documents, work, intermediate work product that
a lawyer uses when completing a project.
Right.
So the agents dropped into this environment and it's given
an instruction, right?
And the instruction is not a detailed list of hey,
here are all of the things you need to do.
It's a partner level instruction, right?
Which is, hey, here's a data room, go write me
an issues list.
And then you have to circle back with the complete
work product.
So that's the context that the agent's given.
It needs to rely on both its priors for how
legal work is done as well as tools and kind
of harness, harness skills, those sort of things that has
available to it.
It's asked to produce real legal work product.
So it's not just a chat based kind of interface
a chat answer.
The agent has to produce real word docs, Excel spreadsheets,
PowerPoints, potentially many of them 5 to 10 of them
in a single in a single scope of a task.
And then it's graded using expert rubrics, right.
So each task has about 50 plus rubric criteria that
specify all of the material points that are are considered
a good work product.
So overall we have coverage of 24 legal practice areas
over 1200 tasks total and I think up to 75,000
total rubber criteria.
So we're really excited about this for benchmarking to spawn
a number of of research directions that I think we'll
talk about and to to start running open weight models
and post training over as well.
It's amazing.
It's great to have industry specific benchmarks because then you
can truly capture how the models do on industry specific
task and actually the all pass criteria which you have
is very, very strict, very high measure of is the
agent truly doing the task the human would do.
So that's amazing.
We'd love to talk about the work we have been
doing together on fine tuning and using the work on
GLM 5.1 and use the custom harness work on top
of it if you want to talk about that a
little bit.
Yeah, we actually published an article today morning about this.
You can check it out.
Yeah, a lot of interesting work streams going on.
As I mentioned, Lab is not just a benchmark, we
really view it as a foundation for research into all
of these areas that are important for production deployments at
the application layer.
So think post training of open weight models, harness optimizations,
how do you bake domain specificity into an agent harness
as well as things like skills tool use more cutting
edge, cutting edge kind of frontier things like memory etcetera.
So with the fireworks team, we're partnering on a number
of of research tracks including kind of straightforward post training
like SFT with Kimi models.
We've shown some nice improvements there in terms of lift
on labs kind of all pass scoring criteria over the
base model.
But that the track that I'm most excited about which
we did publish today.
So go check it out.
Is this work on advisor agents, right?
So we've effectively built a system that leverages worker agents
that are driven by open weight models like GLM 5.1
and then call to advisor models that are heavier, in
many cases closed source frontier models like Opus 4.7.
And it turns out that you can effectively navigate the
Pareto frontier of quality and cost by leveraging these hybrid
systems that effectively do inference time routing.
And so that's what the plot is showing here is
essentially with a closed frontier, you know, you're getting the
frontier of performance, but it often comes with significant cost
and latency trade-offs, open weight models, much cheaper, much faster,
greater security guarantees.
But with that trade off in in performance and with
this hybrid system, not only are we maintaining quality at
a lower cost and latency, but we're actually improving it
in many cases.
So really excited line of work and I think we're
going to continue to build upon it.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
To 2.4 X cheaper on a task where it's about
30% better on the all pass metric, which is really,
really cool.
I think I was talking about this earlier in the
session, like a lot of the companies are using the
frontier close model for all tasks.
It's like having an aircraft carrier to point at a
bunker as well as to point at an Ant.
You don't need that.
Like you, you have to have judgement on where and
what kind of models are needed.
And open models are actually really good on that one.
Actually, I would love to hear Harvey's strategy around open
models in general.
Like, why do you think it's important for Harvey to
leverage open models?
Yeah.
So I think what's great about partnership like ours with
Fireworks is there's kind of two sides here, right.
There's the consumption of open weight models based models through
a managed inference provider.
We're interested in using these out-of-the-box.
And then there's also this question of, hey, can we
improve open weight models via post training, right.
So we're investing in both parts of this equation.
And with respect to post training in particular, I think
there are four kind of key considerations here that make
this an extremely kind of compelling premise for us.
The first, everyone thinks we're going to say cost and
latency first.
It's definitely there.
The 1st is actually domain expertise, right?
So what we've seen through our evaluations is that there's
a significant element of jagged intelligence, right?
And So what that means is this is a phrase
coined by Andre Carpathy.
It refers to this observation that we've we've sort of
seen in many different verticals and with language models generally
that they're really, really good at certain things and then
they fail miserably at other things.
And it's really hard to, to, to interpret a reason
about why that is for any given model, right?
And we see the same thing and legal, right, a
model might be really strong at transactional work like corporate
M&A, financial due diligence, but poor at litigation work like
case law, research, writing intensive tasks, something like that, right?
And so via post training, we can kind of smoothen
out these rough edges and bring the model up to
speed across all practice areas, disciplines, types of work.
So that's one cost and latency is the second factor.
I think you described it perfectly as you don't need
to bring the Ferrari off of the racetrack if you
don't need to.
I think we see sort of a bimodal distribution of
usage emerging, right, where for really high stakes, really complex
work, you'll pay a premium, use the frontier closed source
models, but there's also a lot of simpler work that
open weight models are, are perfectly well suited for.
So routing between these two modes is, is going to
become increasingly important.
And then something that we think about a lot that
I think the industry as a whole is, is starting
to come around to is security and governance, right.
So for the highest stakes type of work, you know,
what our customers are really asking us for is a
secure deployment within the RVPC.
Open weight models enable that by also having access to
things like the complete reasoning trace of the model, you
can do much greater interpretability, auditability work on top of
the behavior of an agent, which is increasingly becoming important
for compliance reasons over time.
So all that is to say, both the consumption of
open wave models and post training increasingly important for us
at Harvey.
All the points that you put forward and the expertise
and the agent work that you're talking about, if you
can double click on that and speak a bit more
about the end to end iteration cycle with fireworks and
what's possible today that was not possible previously, that would
be great.
Yeah.
So within the manage inference side, it's basically plug and
play, which is great because you don't need to do
that iteration, right.
So we can start consuming open source models pretty pretty
quickly.
And then with all of the work that you've done
around managed training infrastructure, it makes the iteration loop much
tighter, much faster, much more efficient.
We have a saying at Harvey, it's that all timelines
are are compressed, right?
And this sort of dynamic AI landscape and environment that
we're in, that applies to research as well, right?
So being able to pick up the pace on things
like post training experiments, running many iterations in parallel and
and in a pretty low touch manner for for our
research team picks up our velocity, which is kind of
a a crucial factor for us.
And like you said, I think at Fireworks, we too
believe that all iteration cycles are compressed.
One thing I would love for you to dive a
little bit deeper on is you've always been an Azure
customer.
So how does this particular foundry with Fireworks partnership really
like help you?
And if there are customers today who are trying to
use the similar platform and path, what advice or recommendation
would you have?
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Well, I mean, this is Microsoft Foundry, right?
When I think of enterprise grade infrastructure, especially AI infrastructure,
I immediately think of Microsoft Foundry, right?
Like I said earlier, legal work is the highest stakes
type of knowledge work.
For that, you need the highest grade of infrastructure, security,
governance, compliance, all of these things, right?
So that's why we've been kind of a happy Azure
customer for this whole time.
And I think that that applies to model training as
well, right?
So with fireworks, it's sort of a best of both
worlds scenario where you can take this enterprise grade infrastructure
that we've already been leveraging and then layer on managed
inference for open weight models, training infrastructure and then seamless
deployment of those models, right?
That's not, you know, significantly handicapping our own infrastructure teams,
right?
So it's a marriage of these two incredible things.
We're very excited about it.
And just to give a little bit of kind of
historical context, when I joined Harvey, we were talking about
this off stage.
We were 5 or 6 people in an Airbnb.
You know, forget innovative AI problems.
It was, you know, we were thinking about whether the
Wi-Fi was on in any given day.
But this was three years ago before a lot of
this AI infrastructure existed, right?
And I can't tell you how relieving it is to
me now and how much better I sleep at night
knowing that we don't have to go figure this all
out ourselves and that we can sort of ride the
tailwinds of your great work and the great work of
your partnership with Microsoft.
So my advice would be if you are a founder
starting an AI native company today and building your AI
stack for the first time, or if you're a larger
enterprise and you're rebuilding your AI stack to be sort
of agent native, I would take, I would ride the
tailwinds that are available to you.
And I would recommend using this, this managed infrastructure.
As we said, all timelines are compressed, so it'll help
you move much much faster.
OK.
Thank you so much for your time in coming here
and talking about Harvey itself.
And just as Nico said, if you were starting a
new use case or reimagining your use case and already
using Azure, then do go out and check out fireworks
models on Azure itself.
You have different modes that you can deploy and integrate
into your agents, whether you're using agents on Azure or
agents that you've built yourself as well.
Thank you for your time and happy to take any
questions for Niko, Vivek or myself as well.